tucked away in the attic apartment of
this nondescript of Wichita home is a
quixotic filmmaker RG Miller is a 53
year old up to who's to making home
movies the scope of blockbusters and
when it comes to his self-described
internet art film RG does it all at our
G studios I'm the director the produce
testing writer the editor the actor the
prop master you name it I wear many hats
these are doing is I weigh from nearly
40 years with prolific results
altogether
I've made 46
[Music]
oh geez internet art films like any film
start with a script like any film coming
out of Hollywood a real good one there
has to be a little bit of yourself in
there or else is that's the point that's
what my story lines for me come from
this an expression appeared for a
hardliner is the expressions of dealing
with society from there it's not the
prop cos you've been set designed which
RG handles was in his own way you feel
my shoulder you see cheeks back here in
law that was an old mask that I had cut
it up so I start placing them like you
would a puzzle on a plastic bottom that
fits the description in my mind I think
that's kind of the voice I want whatever
that case by making whatever
[Music]
next up are you getting to character of
our drawing inspiration from his life
including some of its darker moments I'm
processing my expressions my motion is
my anger by fits and my diction trying
to be perfect and flawless see that
delusion of God so to know that's
already making these themes you know has
a replace of the addition that I want
had you brought to come in here look at
my studio LG studio this is the
addiction but it's a process addiction
because I'm examining it I'm not
allowing it to consume me like I did the
drugs and alcohol down once the scene is
shot RG cut together his vision for me
the best part of making in and off him
is the actual process of putting it
together and the results are unlike
anything you've ever seen I was hungry
G even after all this hard work crowds
aren't exactly flocking to Miller's
films I will probably get an average
between two and three people a week that
will watch something on my internet
YouTube channel one keep doing this with
little to no audience for me they are
therapeutic Oh my films allow me to
examine my emotion once you examine
something you can edit out the things
that you don't like or you can change
the things that you you know you have an
opportunity to change to your to your
satisfaction
[Music]